all right we have a graph of y is equal
to f of x and we want to figure out what
is the limit of f of x as x approaches
negative three
and if we just look at x equals negative
three it's really hard to see at least
based on how this graph looks how what f
of negative three is and if anything it
looks like we have we have an asymptotic
discontinuity here it looks like on the
left side of x equals negative three it
looks like we're approaching
i guess you could say infinity and on
the right side it looks like we're
approaching infinity as well and we
could just look at that we could say
well look what is f of negative 5 well
it's 4 f of negative 4 is looks like
it's around i don't know around 8. f of
negative 3 is off the charts f of
negative if we continued with this trend
and if we were to asymptote towards this
line right over here this vertical
asymptote it looks like as we get closer
and closer to negative 3 that the value
of the function at that point is
approaching is getting closer and closer
to infinity at least that's what it
looks like from what we can see on this
graph as we approach negative 3 from the
left-hand side let's think about what's
as we approach negative 3 from the
right-hand side so this is f of negative
1 f of negative 2 f of negative
2.5 looks like it's up here someplace x
f of negative 2.9 would be even higher f
of negative 2.999 it looks like it would
just once again approach infinity
so this type of limit
in some context you would say that this
limit doesn't exist
doesn't
doesn't exist in the formal
sense so that's one way to think about
it in some in some context you will
people you will
hear people say that this limit since
from the left and from the right it
looks like it's going to infinity
sometimes you will see people say that
it is approaching infinity and so this
is depending on what type of a class
what type of a context you're in but in
the traditional sense of the limit or in
the technical sense there there are ways
that you can define limits where this
would make a little bit more sense but
the the traditional definition of a
limit it would be you would say that
this limit does not exist